Speaker 1: It is great to be joined today
by Sam Quinones, who is author of the New
York Times bestseller Dreamland The True Tale
of America's Opiate Epidemic and most recently,
The Last of US, True Tales of America and
Hope in the time of fentanyl and meth.
Speaker 2: Sam, it's great to have you on.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 4: Thank you for having me. David,
good to good
Speaker 2: to be with you. So, I mean,
Speaker 1: just from just from the titles
of the two books, right? There's been a change
in in what is happening in the United States
as far as drugs go. Can you talk a little
bit about I mean, how has the landscape changed
from when you were researching the first book
and then now the second, the most recent one?
Speaker 4: Sure. Of course, it really has
changed dramatically and quite unexpectedly
to me. Honestly, when I was writing the first
book, the idea was to write the story of how
we had gone from a country that had decided
or a medical establishment that the state
decided the idea was a good one to massively
and excessively, in my opinion, prescribe
narcotic painkillers, opioid painkillers for
all manner of pain that they had not been
used for before. And and not just that, but
but like lots of refills and kind of understood
with the understanding or the belief that
that these pills would not be at all addictive
to anyone who was who was a pain patient that
helped a lot of people. Fair to say, it also
created an enormous new population of people
who actually were addicted to these pills
or dependent on these pills. They went to
the street, couldn't find them very well on
the street. It was very expensive. And eventually
they a certain percentage of those folks moved
on to turn to heroin. Or these pills are have
the drugs in them are very similar to heroin.
The underworld then took over, and that's
what led to the next book. The underworld
began, particularly in Mexican trafficking
world began providing the heroin. They then
figured out that actually, it's a much better
idea to make a synthetic form of heroin, which
we now know is that no, you don't need any,
any, any any of the issues, the land or any
other kind of stuff. And and so the transformation
kind of began. And really, about five years
ago, not long after dreamland came out, you
began to see more kind of take over. And now
the country is essentially effectively covered
with fentanyl, which is an opioid, but of
a synthetic one, you don't make use use plants
to make it. And that means that you can make
it year round if you have the chemicals at
the same time. Methamphetamine is also now
covered the country because of a new way of
making that as well. And so you see, really,
we're in the era of synthetic drugs, whereas
before it was, it was the doctors and the
classic underworld providing heroin. Now it's
pretty much the entire source comes from the
underworld, and it's now just synthetic. Yes,
in order to buy
Speaker 1: in advance of our interview, I
read an article that the exact name I now
don't remember, but it's something like Can
you even really call it meth anymore? And
it talks about how now this this mechanism
called P2P, is being used for the manufacture
of meth. Can you talk about why that's been
so crucial to the dominance of meth?
Speaker 4: Sure, that was an excerpt of the
book. In fact, that that was there was run
on The Atlantic, and what happened with methamphetamine
was interesting. Years ago, the Mexican trafficking
world industrialized the production of meth
using a chemical known as ephedrine ephedrine
as a decongestant. You find it in Sudafed
pills. It's chemically very similar to meth,
so you a couple of tweaks and it turns into
meth. It's a it's a kind of a euphoric high,
very sociable. You want to be around people,
you're jabbering away. And they made huge
amounts of it, but they were always limited
by the amount of of ephedrine they could get
and they could really get they could get tons
of it, but it was really only enough to cover
parts of the western United States. No, when
he used the Mississippi River. Eventually,
though, the Mexican government got figured
this out and the response was to make ephedrine
essentially illegal, except for certain pharmaceutical
companies to produce. That meant that the
trafficking world now had a whole body of
knowledge about methamphetamine and no way
to really make it. But there is another way
of making methamphetamine, and they began
to figure that out. It uses a precursor known
as such. As you said, P2P channel to pro bono
and P2P is actually very messy. It stinks
and all that when you turn it into methamphetamine,
it does have one benefit of the chartering
world. And that is that you can make it many,
many different ways with a lots of different
industrial wild. The available industrial
chemicals, all these chemicals are legal,
they're very toxic. But if the government
cracks down on this combination of chemicals,
you can use this other one and there are many
of these combinations. So it allows the trafficking
world if they can get the chemicals to produce
this stuff in staggering quantities. And essentially,
that's what's happening because they have
access to two very large ports and several
smaller ones on the Pacific coast of Mexico,
through which they get access to the world
chemical markets and they can bring in all
the chemicals that they like. Some of these
chemicals actually made in Mexico, of course.
And so what you begin to see it beginning
in about 2012 13 is the production of it is
just staggering, just unbelievable quantities
of the stuff. So much so that it crosses the
Mississippi River, goes across and now is
up into New England, respectively, covering
the country. And it's it's a remarkable, I
guess, dubious achievement. But there's one
other thing that that's very much a part of
that story and that is this that as this methamphetamine
begins to really march across the country
first in the western United States, in the
Midwest in 2017 or so, then up into New England
2019, it's also accompanied by very severe
rapid onset symptoms of paranoia and hallucinations,
symptoms of schizophrenia, essentially very
intense paranoia, very vivid hallucinations,
delusions, people. So it's accompanied by
mental illness and very quickly that mental
illness leads lots of people to be homeless.
So you're see as this mass marches across
the country, you also find big, big escalations
in the amount of mental illness and homelessness
and eventually also tent encampments, because
these folks in this situation in this condition
are not going to be living in homeless shelters,
right?
Speaker 1: I want to talk about that next
because there's been a big this. These encampments
are a
Speaker 2: big topic of
Speaker 1: political controversy. And I, as
someone who is, you know, unabashedly on the
left, I consider myself a progressive. The
research I've done makes me question the
Speaker 2: wisdom of the kind of like,
Speaker 1: let's just leave the encampments,
because if we don't have a great place to
send people who are we to take away the one
place that they found and the piece for me
and all of this that makes me hesitate about
taking that approach is. It's not when you
consider the drug addiction component,
Speaker 2: there seems to be zero possibility
that folks
Speaker 1: get out of that cycle if they remain
in the encampment. Now breaking up the encampment
raises all sorts of other questions. Where
do people go?
Speaker 2: Is it safe? It's I'm not
Speaker 1: denying that, but it seems that
you have no possibility of drilling dealing
with the drug component if the encampment
stay. What's your experience with that?
Speaker 4: No, I would say that in talking
with people who work with these folks and
recovering addicts as well, I would say that's
absolutely true and it's really actually a
little bit more even serious than that because.
Talking with folks about this issue very clearly,
quickly get the idea that there, that the
effect of this of this methamphetamine is
really almost at least semi-permanent brain
damage. It's not like what the federal meth.
You would stay up for several days and you
would begin to see kind of shadow people and
then you would sleep it off and you would
return to coherence. Not that this was good
for you. It just was not the damage now. Now
people are saying, and I was just speaking
with a homeless shelter provider here in Nashville,
where I'm now living for for a while. And
she was saying that the brand devastation
makes it so that you can't really teach these
folks to function. So the longer they are
exposed out on the street, particularly in
tent encampments, which really exist as vectors
of methamphetamine frequently, even though,
of course, tents were meant with good intentions.
They're really kind of a place now where meth
flows flows freely. That's why they exist,
because people, it's like the bar where everybody
knows your name in a sense. Well, this is
the same thing. And so what really is happening
is that prolonged exposure to this is it is
very scary. And I met people who've who've
recovered from it and are now sober, but they
still know they tell me that someone told
me this. I still know I'm not the same. My
brain is still not fully healed, and some
of these folks have been sober a year or two.
There's still that paranoia. There's still
that slow the memory is is really faded. And
certainly it takes weeks, maybe even months
for the personality of a person to return.
So it's the prolonged exposure in these cameras,
as you say, I think makes it extraordinarily
difficult for those folks to ever recover
to something close to what they were beforehand.
Speaker 1: So sometimes it's very popular
to talk about Portugal when one talks about
drug policy and treatment. And one of the
things that sometimes folks don't know about
Portugal is it's not that in Portugal, there's
no consequences for drug addiction. It's that
they are handled
Speaker 2: as health issues
Speaker 1: rather than criminal issues. But
there are consequences. There can be mandated
treatment there. People are taken out of the
equivalent of the encampment, so to speak.
So in thinking about solutions
Speaker 2: like what has worked
Speaker 1: what or what might work?
Speaker 4: Well, I do. I do believe that that
some form of mandated treatment is is what's
necessary here, because what you're looking
for in our treatment, you have to come to
a point where you embrace your sobriety, where
you embrace recovery. The problem is that
that is not possible on the street today.
First of all, you have fentanyl, which will
kill you before you ever develop any kind
of readiness for treatment, right? Whole idea
you need to be ready for treatment. It's true.
But the problem is, how do you get there?
Where and how long does it take? And and I
think on the street, it's very difficult.
And with them, the meth encampment in the
mess world, it's very hard for people to first
of all, in order for recovery to take place,
you actually have to be able to talk rationally
with other people. It's a human connection
that is essential for that process to move,
to move forward. And if you were speaking
in what they call in psychology word salad.
So, yeah, the jumbles of words and tumbling
out of your mouth, you had no idea what people
had. No idea what you're saying. There's no
ability to develop that deep connection. So
first and foremost, detox and prolonged detox,
not a few days, but weeks. And then an idea
that forced treatment because the drugs control
is so profound. And that's what a homeless
outreach guy told me. He'd been doing this
five years. And he says, you know, everybody
I've offered treatment to and housing to when
I get them into housing very quickly, they
just bolt and they leave and they run back
to the encampment. So you need to get people
away from that someplace, secure someplace
where they are mandated treatment, someplace
where they begin, the process that careful
nudging, gradual process of coming to embrace
their own sobriety, which will happen. But
it does mean that separation
Speaker 1: from yeah, that's an important
point, which is when when addiction is a factor,
just giving homeless
Speaker 2: folks homes alone does not
Speaker 1: actually solve the problem. Are
there communities in the U.S. that are doing
this correctly?
Speaker 4: I mean, I think with methamphetamine,
it's so new on the story, really. I was I
broke this story in the book and unless enlisting
in the Atlantic, you know about methamphetamine,
and I think many community is kind of almost
didn't know what they had. First of all, COVID
has kind of overshadowed everything last year
or two. And then before that, the opioid epidemic
overshadowed the meth thing. So people have
really not come to understand the deep issues
involved with methamphetamine. Some places
are.
Speaker 1: Oh, Sam, we just lost you, we first
lost your video and then we lost your audio,
now you're back, sorry. You just
Speaker 2: glitched for for a moment there,
Speaker 1: really? Yeah, but now you're back.
You're you're smooth now.
Speaker 4: So OK, well, I would say that then
a lot of places are still trying to figure
this thing out because first of all, I think
the opioid epidemic overshadowed the Mets
problem. And then also then COVID did the
same. So what we're seeing now is people are
just kind of now coming to understand this.
I would say that in Clarksburg, West Virginia,
I write about in the book several chapters
in the book. They tried the Housing First
idea and the folks that they put into housing
destroyed. There were some refurbished apartments
that they were able to put them in and they
destroyed the apartments. They were, you know,
$100000 worth of damage to these apartments.
There was no way they could do it. So I think
people are just now. I mean, really because
the story just I just breaking with this book
and know people are just now becoming to the
point where they're saying, let's see if what
we can try. I spoke with salt with with a
politician in Northern California who was
thinking we were talking about the possibility
of using empty big-box stores to put a kind
of controlled tent encampment like put tents
within a secure big box, store controlled
entry and exit and so on. And have that be
a place where maybe people detox for the first?
But I haven't found anybody who's been able
to deal significantly with this issue. That's
that this new meth coming out of Mexico has
presented over the last several years.
Speaker 1: Sometimes people will call in and
they'll say, Hey, are you
Speaker 2: for legalization
Speaker 1: of all drugs,
Speaker 2: just like we're starting to see
Speaker 1: with cannabis in some states? And
you know, I I feel very strongly that decriminalization
is really important. And it's there's a number
of reasons why that seems like an easier thing
to think about. And there are good examples
from around the world when I think about like
recreational meth or recreational heroin.
These drugs seem so destructive to just one's
basic ability to exist in the world that I
have not been convinced that recreational
legalization of these makes any sense. How
do you conceive of this issue?
Speaker 4: I think not. I guess, you know,
I would like to see. Here's what I would like
to see. I guess first, I would like to see
us legalize marijuana in a mature and adult
way. We are doing it as if, you know, if it's
if it's a if it's a consumable, then we need
to have those places inspected, like food
factories are inspected. If it's a medicine,
we need to have them inspected, like like
factories that produce drugs are inspected.
I think it's absolutely insane in a time of
climate change that we allow indoor grown
marijuana among a plant that grows beautifully
outdoors. That should not be possible. And
the idea, too, that we are not going to, after
all, now we're going to be arresting people
for selling marijuana is is crazy to now.
You're seeing dispensaries in California say
we have to compete now with illegal vendors
who don't have to pay taxes, electricity or
rent and all the rest. And so you need to
lower our taxes, know what we need to do is
we need a prolonged, prolonged time period,
probably many years of very aggressive enforcement
of people who are selling the drug illegally
so that there won't be that that unfair competition
for folks who actually have to pay rent and
electricity and taxes and all the rest that
we want. Like any liquor store or any other
place, you know, to me, this feels like. And
I also believe that we need to to really question
what the potency should be that we allow for
it for commercial, for commercial sale. It's
insane 40 percent THC, 90 percent THC and
vapes. And this guy, I mean, and these little
candy things, I mean, you know, when Joe Camel
started marketing cigarets to kids, the entire
country was up in arms. And yet it's OK to
have these little gummy bears and all that
kind of stuff. To me, it feels like and I
think part of this grows from the fact that
we still don't have federal. Marijuana legends
say a really federal marijuana legislation
needs to put all of this and much more in
into place, but a lot of this stuff seems
to me to be almost juvenile. Like it doesn't
really matter, dude. It's just pot. Well,
it's it's not. Pot is very potent stuff, and
it needs to be treated that way and we need
to approach it like adults. I want to see
that done first, and then we can turn our
attention to whether other drugs. But I don't
really see it happening in what we do this
right?
Speaker 1: No doubt about it. The latest book
Is The Least of US, True Tales of America
and Hope in the Time of Fentanyl and Meth.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Sam Quinones. Sam, great having you on today.
Speaker 4: I love being with you, David. Thanks
so much.